from afar these mountains in the french
alps seem picture-perfect but up close
scientists are finding more of this
red patches known as snow blood
the color is actually microscopic algae
scientists suspect it turns red to
protect itself from intense sun rays
when it's in the snow it accumulates a
pigment like sunscreen to protect itself
from the light intensity it's the same
concept as people going skiing and
putting on sunscreen so fundamentally
the algae is still green but it's hidden
behind a big shield of red pigment
about 2
500 meters above sea level a team of
experts is collecting samples to see if
climate change is fueling snow blood
researchers say it appears to be part of
a vicious cycle
when the level of carbon dioxide
increases in the atmosphere we find red
snow more often it's likely linked to
global warming and the warmer it is the
more algae appears and the more algae
the faster the snow melts
snow levels are dropping as a result of
rising temperatures and the alps have
been hit disproportionately hard
locals who are out in the mountains tell
us they're seeing these formations of
red snow in the early summer some of the
patches can be subtle but others can be
extremely strong
if it continues scientists say excessive
snow melt in the alps has the potential
to affect entire ecosystems far beyond
its mountains
katie lopez
al jazeera